ينضم الينا الان من غاز عنتاب نفسها
الطبيب في الجمعيه الطبيه السوريه
الامريكيه دكتور حمزه حسن دكتور حمزه
ضعنا في صوره ما تتعاملون معه كاطباء الان
بعد هذا الزلزال على مستوى الجرحى او عدد
الجثث التي تم انتشالها من المباني
المتضرره
الله يعطيكم العافيه جميعا الحياه الوضع
في شمال سوريا وضع سيء للغايه يعني
ما فيه تتكشف شيئا فشيئا احد مشافي
مشافينا تضرر بشكل جزئي وهو المشكل الاكبر
لامراض التوليد والاطفال في
مدينه الدانه تم اخلاء المرضى والكادر
الحمد لله بسلام ولكن وقفنا الخدمه فيه
عم اعمل احاله للمشاكل الاخرى
جزء من مشافينا فقد تضرر باضرار منها خفيف
منها متوسط ولكن فقط مشهد دانه هي اللي
توقفت عنها نتيجه الاضرار الجسيمه اللي
صارت فيها
كمان نحن حوالي 84
قتيل نتيجه هذا الزلزال وصل الى مشاكل
جمعيه الطبيه السوريه الامريكيه حتى هذه
اللحظه
اكبر عدد لهذا هؤلاء القتلى في او ضحايا
نتيجه الزلزال في مدينه الاثارب مع حوالي
الخمسين
ضحيه
وباقي ضحيه عم تتوزع في
باقي باقي الاماكن للاسف هلا بيصبروني انه
في
بعض الكوادر كمان يعني الطبيه اللي بتشتغل
معنا
ننتظر تاكيد المعلومات انه في منهن مع
اهاليهم يعني
رفض ضحيه هذا الزلزال مشافينا هلا حاليا
كلياتها اوفر وين
اسعافنا كلياته عم يشتغل بكامل طاقته نحن
عما خبرنا كل الاطباء المناودين والممرضين
التحقوا بالمشافي حاليا احنا بنتجهز بنجهز
حتى
نرفع من اسره الاستقبال واسره للعنايه
حنحاول ننصح من اسره العنايه للضغط
والضعفين حسب ما نحن
نستطيع يعني هاي هي الحاله بطبيعه الاحوال
نحن حاليا عم نخاف من
زياده الحالات نتيجه نحن لحتى اللحظه ما
عم نحسن نقدر حجم الضحايا بشكل كبير نتيجه
انقطاع الاتصالات والنتيجه البطء في
عمليات الانقاذ يعني
حاليا
الجرحى ما تجينا بشكل متتابع
نتيجه بطء عمليات الانقاذ من تحت الانقاذ
ما هي ابرز الحاجات الان دكتور على مستوى
هذه المستشفيات
هلا
ابرز الحاجات هلا حاليا
بعض الادويه الاسعافيه يعني حاجه اسعافير
لتفعيل
اكبر عدد من الاسره واسره العنايه لانه ما
بتعرفوا بهيك حالات بتزيد الاصابات
والحاجه الى العنايه المركزه نحن حنحاول
نشتغل يلي بنقدر عليه ولكن يبدو الحاجه
اكثر
مما هو يعني متوقع عدد المتوافدين اذا على
هذه المستشفيات من جرحى ومصابين يفوق قدره
هذه المستشفيات على التعامل معهم
الاحتياجات هي على مستوى الادويه
الاسعافيه كما ذكرت اسره
العنايه الى من توجهون نداء المساعده الان
دكتور
حاليا نوجه نداء
المساعده والاغاثه لكل من يستطيع ان ينقذ
هذا الشاعر في شمال غرب سوريا المنطقه هي
فقيره فقيره بكل المعدات هل الانقاذ فقيره
باساسها فقيره بالشلتر والماوى ونعرف
مرحله المخيمات نتيجه العاصفه الثلجيه
والعاطفه المطريه اللي هلا تجري حاليا كل
مين قصتيها ان يساعد بالاموال او
يعني بالمعدات يا ريت يساعدنا نحن بحاجه
دوليه
الاصابات التي وصلت الى المستشفيات
خطورتها
كيف يجري تقييم وضع المصابين بشكل عام
متل ما بتعرفوا مناطق شمال غير سوريا
المشافينا عندها خبره كبيره بمجال الردود
والتروما
ومعالجه
الجرحى الردود يعني الاصابات اغلبها هي عم
تيجي اصابات مغلقه نتيجه الردم يعني نتيجه
هؤلاء الضحايا عما ينزل عليهم
ردم المنازل اشياء
ثقيله يعني بشكل عام هي ردود مغلقه مسميها
نحن هي النزول في الدماغيه الكسور العظميه
الاذيات الهرسيه كلياتها هاي طبيعه
الاصابات بهيك
بهيك حالات
شكرا